uh
I'm
here if you ever ask yourself the
question faite hobby with your job this
is maybe
yet welcome to Json
Asia maybe the first conference that's
introduced from
underwater it's pretty cool in here
actually you should try it out
later I can see you a bit can you cheer
or do
anything that is
awesome I got to take a video of you
guys later like just to show you
afterwards how it looks from me inside
here it's pretty
cool well so JavaScript conference for
Asia that's kind of what we started last
year in
Singapore and uh really what this is
about is to inspire you guys a little to
contribute to be open to be part of the
big open source Community out there and
to learn a lot and you know we have
awesome speakers for the next two
days uh
yeah I'm a bit fascinated by the fish
here
funny and uh I hope you enjoy this thing
so I got to introduce Rico Rico Santa
Cruz is your host he's the local maybe
the most well-known Filipino JavaScript
developer over here I can see
you uh he's going to take over
all right than and uh introduce you to
the conference and get everything going
well I'll going to film a little bit
take some
photos and uh come back with you later
and I hope you enjoy the conference and
I want some more cheer
please
aw can you get this
on on
video how this thing
work right ready all right thank
Thomas so again said welcome to the
2013 Json Asia in
Mana